In the very,
very bad shootouts man,
the Kelvin gassed alum style
bend to fight was a shootout.
Best style of fight from me I've ever,
ever.
It's one of the best fights of
all time has to be. It has to be.
And when you see style than to get
rocked in the first row dropped.
You like Ho Lee Shit. I think he's
the best thing that happened to them.
It's a good thing. I think it's a good
thing for career wise and going forward.
It's a good thing you
face a little adversity.
We see that he's not going to get
hit and crumble and you got one.
You got a special dude in style bender
and how good is Calvin? God Damn,
he's Tom Faster.
He's so fucking tough.
And even after all that,
I mean style bender was teeing off on
him in that fifth round and Calvin is
finding a way to survive. I'm going
to say great chin, incredible style.
Benders face looked like he
was allergic to shellfish
face.
How put fourth round he was
happening then the band,
he was in a war Kelvin hidden with some
bombs. Man Bombs. Yeah, and it's also,
I think it's good. We saw, we saw a,
you get hit and getting knocked
down or saw him get taken down.
We saw what happens when he's off
his back. Look pretty fucking do it.
He's triangle.
He's in triangle locked up.
Who knows what the fuck would have
happened if that was early in the fight,
they were dry. So I think that that fight
for stopped and checked all the boxes,
but also what's great about this is
Kelvin stock doesn't go down. No.
If anything, I'd watch that guy fight
whenever, whenever, and let's be honest,
he's really a welterweight.
Correct. He's super small. For me,
Deron till can make 170 pounds soaking
Calvin. It's a discipline thing. Yes.
I just think there should be more
weight classes. I don't even think it's,
I don't think he's a doctor.
Your boy,
Dana Man isn't one of those 65
you could text him. You don't get,
no one listens to me and I don't
want them to really? Yeah, I do.
I'd rather just stay out here and talk
about it. Yeah. I want it to evolve.
The lap pushed it. I've said, I think
there should be a weight class everyday.
I gotta get Outta here. We could
dangle the carrot and be like, Yo,
we'll do a fight companion every time
a one 65 or fights and just dangle that
carrot. Yeah, he's surprised at one do it.
Probably still wouldn't do it. It's um,
it's one of those things where like,
I think they'd like it the way it is.
If it ain't broke, don't fix it. Yeah.
But it doesn't make sense because if
you're going to do all these intern belts,
why not do 65? I think they
built on belts, on belts.
Do you think they would
think that it's watered down?
They have too many weight classes that
people would just be jumping back and
forth from weight class, which they would
be talking about chaos, which I love.
But you would also have people that
find a way class where they could be at
their best versus either have to bulk
up or have to drop too much weight and
compromise herself. But her happy
medium for a lot of guys that are not,
they're not hitting that
happy medium right now.
We're not getting the best performance.
But here's the thing about,
so if Calvin should be one seven
year style benders are smaller.
The fiber he weighed in at one 83 up.
He weighed under the weight limit.
So look at how big some of these
guys are. Oh my God. Brandon Davis,
two 35 35 he was one 60 dude.
That was Brandon neighbors, right?
Was that,
who said that?
Some of those 80 fibers like you
look at jock gray cat Yoel Romero.
Joe Ramirez checking antic dude, it
looks like. We'll see what I mean,
it's going to happen.
Think about it.
You'll Ramiro stopping like
y'all remember Jack? Dude,
it's a big fight style.
Benner could probably make one 70 easier
then fucking 85 [inaudible] 80 Pfizer a
big weight classes.
Yeah,
that's why you have you seen
the talk and makes no sense.
Style bender and Jon Jones. That's
crazy. What are we doing? Who?
Who the fuck's picking up on?
It's just cause they're talking shit.
W what do you just the last card.
Just a,
it just says, yeah, he ballooned back up
260 pounds. Yeah, it was Brandon Davis.
Right from 35 it's really talented.
It's crazy when I'm standing next to him
that this guy waiting at 35 cause I'm
looking at him, he looked all of 165
pounds. I was like this, he looks so,
he's five 10 he looks so big for
that one 35 pound weight class.
Like this is crazy.
Well Eve Max at 45 fucking huge.
But the UFC performance institute gave
him the green light to do that. Wow.
So they must have known what they were
doing. Says David Swipe with cost,
who was a first in the bandwidth division,
said he needed to make serious
sacrifices to get there.
He said he cut out drinking alcohol
on his shit and ran 20 miles per day.
The terroir in order to make the weight.
By the time he stepped into the octagon
to 36 he had ballooned back to me to see
this dude. He's really, really
like, man, he must be huge.
For the thing is at the,
he was also,
he was not just like tall. He said,
he's like, he's thick. Like you can,
it's weird how you can lose that much
weight, but why not just fight at 45?
Why Kill Yourself? Like why do
I fight at 45 he fought a beat.
Know his last fight. Well, yeah,
as a beat. Magomed Sharapov um,
it's a beat. Got Him in that
crazy arm bar from the back leg.
Leg locked in the back. Yeah. Which is so
nasty from fail back. Mount fails. Nasty.
There's two that night. I know. It's
crazy. That's a crazy move. Right? Crazy.
But I think when I think of one 85 years,
think of Luke Rockhold he shoot, man.
Yeah, it's a big ass. He's huge.
But then Whitaker's not like,
I think freakish a big, I
think Luke's done with 85.
Yeah, he's at two oh five now.
He has a fight lined up already.
But I mean,
is he going to stay there as you
just doing it for one five for sure.
You stay in there.